like it I love it is Elliott Brown
really Jojo C was family friend or is he
much more will share what we know about
this football player including whether
he's 28 or 18
although Jojo is quick to dismiss dating
rumor she did admit to having a crush on
someone we would all recognize Elliott
is his name he has been a family friend
of mine dancing queen Jojo C hua loves
to keep up with her fans on social media
and we love to see her awesome dance
moves but in one tick-tock video she
took a break from busting a move to
answer some fan questions and we learned
something interesting when Jojo asked if
she has a lover she quickly replied I do
not despite this many fans think she's
seeing a certain someone from her past
maybe she just prefers the term
boyfriend so she was technically still
telling the truth this mystery man is
Elliot Brown and there's a reason why
JoJo's fans on social media we're losing
their minds over the possibility of them
dating no it's not because Jojo might
actually have a boyfriend it's because
they thought she was dating someone way
too old for some reason Google was
reporting that Elliot Brown is 28 years
old considering the fact that JoJo's 16
years old it's not hard to see why this
had some people seriously upset but you
can relax because in reality Elliot is
just a couple years older than Jojo is
his birthday is April 4th 2002 making
him 18 and not 28 like some people
thought much to our relief Jojo and
Elliot are close in age but how did this
cute potential couple meet according to
Jojo they've known each other a long
time starting when she was about 8 years
old their families have been close to
each other and when Jojo and Elliot
started spending time together recently
this brightly colored fashionista knew
exactly what would happen she and Elliot
discussed the best way to describe their
relationship when people asked and
decided to refer to themselves as family
friends but if you think they could be
more than friends someday you're in good
company Jojo doesn't seem surprised that
her fans think she and Elliot should be
a couple and that might be because their
families think so too she describes his
family as the nicest people ever and
admits that her family jokes that she
and Elliot would be cute together based
on what we've seen of them together we
definitely have to agree we all know
Jojo is a talented girl who sings dances
rocks hair bows and goes crazy for candy
but what about Elliot
the two met in Nebraska where they both
grew up and while Jojo moved to Los
Angeles
Elliott stayed behind and has been
focusing on high school and his football
career as a senior he was a Class A
honorable mention all-state choice and
received scholarship offers from
Northwest Missouri State Augustana and
UNK he's fast on the field which could
explain why he's able to keep up with
the always energetic Jojo dating long
distance is never easy and this could be
a reason why Jojo is content calling
Elliott her family friend at least for
now because despite getting plenty of
offers Elliott has decided to stay put
in his home state of Nebraska he's set
to join the Nebraska Cornhuskers
football program as a preferred walk-on
Elliott will make the switch from high
school quarterback to wide receiver at
Nebraska University apparently Elliott
isn't eager to leave Nebraska and called
joining the Cornhuskers a tradition that
you can't pass up it seems like Elliott
loves sports as much as Jojo loves to
dance but that doesn't mean they don't
have things in common
rumors that Elliott and Jojo are dating
kicked up into high gear when the two of
them were seen spending time together
they took a trip to Six Flags Magic
Mountain you know the same place Kylie
Jenner run it out for Travis Scott's
birthday while Jojo didn't book the
whole place for her hang style she and
Elliott did spend some time together in
her house wearing amazing matching
outfits whether or not they're dating
there is no denying they look great
together especially with those glittery
shoes you know what they say the couple
who twins together wins together since
Jojo clearly cares about Elliott her
fans have started wondering just who she
is and if you're hoping for hints you
might want to head on over to his
tik-tok account there are plenty of
videos of him dancing but he also took
the time to clear up some facts for
JoJo's fans who found themselves
googling him
of course he clarified that he's 18 and
not 28 and then shared that his
astrological sign is Aries he's 6 feet
tall and his favorite color is red now
that we have a better idea of Elliott's
basic traits let's take a look at what
makes him so special we all know JoJo's
totally sweet and not just because her
mansion is stocked with candy but
Elliott has a tender heart too
especially when it comes to his little
McKinley blue this brave little girl was
badly injured in a car accident and had
to relearn how to walk talk and even
beat herself
Elliott knew McKinley threw his own
little sisters and started
visiting her in the hospital she started
developing strength back in her arm by
painting Elliot's nails before his game
and this tradition continued once she
was happily at home
according to Eliot's mom Sarah Brown he
just wanted to do what he could to bring
a smile to McKinley's face McKinley and
Jojo aren't the only people Elliot loves
to spend time with while Jojo helps
Elliot work on his moves he passes the
love along to people like his friend
Ethan who has Down syndrome
Elliot isn't shy about spending time
with others including those with special
needs we all love following Jojo on
social media and it seems like Elliot is
following in her footsteps by launching
his own YouTube channel
he has just under 2,000 subscribers so
far but we're excited to see how his
channel develops especially since he
says he'll be releasing new videos every
Wednesday and Saturday
could he be as big as Jojo someday or
will she continue to be the more famous
friend whether you follow Elliot on
Instagram or his tik-tok account you
might see a familiar face from time to
time he's shared quite a few clips of
himself and Jojo dancing together and
although he claims he can't dance he
looks like he's having a ton of fun we
think he's got some great moves
but if he's feeling insecure about his
dancing ability he should definitely
start spending more time with Jojo even
though Elliot's a teen he's already had
some eat he's got a tattoo of a cross on
his right arm and it's clear his faith
is a big part of his life in fact he
even listed it along with family and
friends as things that inspire him in
one of his tip-top videos if Elliot
wants to keep up with Jojo he's going to
have to take care of himself this
football player had surgery on his
shoulder which is why you'll see his arm
is in a blinged-out sling in so many of
his photos and videos but don't worry
because this injury didn't stop him from
being able to dance he also started
working out again and seems to be well
on his way to recovery
Jojo clearly thinks Elliot is one of a
kind but he sees himself as similar to
some other celebs he created a tick tock
video set to the tune of this could be
us by race drummer and compared his look
to some famous figures these include
Macklemore mark-paul Gosselaar Dolph
Lundgren and The Fabulous fictional
Johnny Bravo
although Jojo and sushi and Elliot are
platonic pow some fans think there's
something
or going on between them but Jojo
statements aren't surprising considering
what she said about the possibility of
dating people in the past who is very
nice and very sweet even though Jojo
makes it look so easy
there's no denying she's a girl on the
go she's super busy and doesn't know how
she'd managed to find time for a
boyfriend in her busy schedule
Jojo said she's enjoying being young and
living her life and doesn't feel the
need to have a relationship at this
point in time but still there's a reason
fans have always speculated about her
love life during a video where she went
over frequently googled questions about
herself she claimed one of them was
regarding her single status while she
answered the other challenging question
like is Jojo C hua alive she pointedly
didn't address the one about whether or
not she was single Jojo did address one
rumor regarding a potential romance
between herself and a fellow youtuber it
seems like every time two stars work
together on a project everyone assumes
they're dating and that's definitely
what happened when Jojo worked with
Maddie B raps she appeared in the music
video for his song right now I'm missing
you and they've collaborated on a few
YouTube videos so it's not surprising
that fans suspected there was something
going on between them
but according to Jojo she and Maddie B
definitely did not date when it comes to
her dating life Jojo usually prefers to
keep quiet about it which is
understandable since she's entitled to
her privacy and she's still a teenager
but during an interview with NBC's
Natalie Morales in 2019 she revealed
that she wants out a serious crush on
someone who we might all know somebody
but oh well Jojo refused to reveal who
she had feelings for she did say that
he's someone her fans are probably
familiar with but even though she had
feelings for them she admitted that they
never actually dated apparently he was
always keeping her on read and she
realized she was falling for the chase
and not the actual guy she admits they
haven't yet met in person but says when
they finally do she's confident they'll
become good friends and nothing more
even if Jojo does have feelings for her
friend Elliott or anyone else would she
actually be able to have a relationship
with them things are already complicated
considering her busy schedule and Jojo
says there's an added difficulty when it
comes to dating
according to Jojo her mom
Lindiwe says she would be cool with her
daughter dating as long as she knew the
guy Wells and he proved himself to her
but JoJo's not buying it and thinks her
mom is way too overprotective to let her
date anyone regardless of how great they
are
since Jojo seems happy being single this
apparently hasn't been an issue yet but
it could be a potential roadblock to a
relationship but for now finding a
boyfriend just isn't a huge motivation
in the star's life during an interview
she strongly stated that she is not
boy-crazy and Natalie Morales said no
maybe just haven't met the right boy
which first of all rude secondly Jojo
says that she's met plenty of boys but
she has other things on her mind right
now from her colorful clothes to her
romantic life it seems like some people
are always trying to force Jojo into
their mold of what it means to be
grown-up but Jojo is happy living her
life focusing on her career and
appreciating her fans who adore her for
who she is do you think Jojo and Elliott
make a cute couple or would you rather
see her with someone else let us know
who you think her perfect match could be
in the comment section and don't forget
to click subscribe for more great videos
from us here at the things bye for now
[Music]